[Music]
three okay time for another movie review
this time around we're doing another
kind of overlooked 1970s sci-fi movie
although it's actually from 1980 yeah
but it's 70ish the way it feels yeah
this one's this one I love this one man
I've seen it many times as a kid on
cable it's called Saturn three Kirk
Douglas Farrah Fawcett Harvey Keitel a
young Harvey Keitel yeah when you see
him you like Dan that's Harvey Keitel
yeah it was very weird to see him in
this movie because he's really young I'm
just used to seeing young and dashing
and he's a villain in this one yeah this
movie actually was kind of a response to
alien alien was a success you know and
this came out eight months later I
remember seeing it in Fangoria magazine
it's just oh man I want to see this one
but my my couldn't get my dad to take me
for one reason or another and then I had
to wait until it came out on cable and I
liked it it was really good kind of the
same premise as alien and Blade Runner
where earth is kind of a bad place there
are no real nation-states it's just
companies and corporations and you got
Farrah Fawcett and Kirk Douglas out on
the on Titan I think it is a third mode
of Saturn and they're working for this
company they got tattoos on their faces
the little company logo and their job is
to grow food underneath the ground
they're doing it hydroponically yeah
grow food for Earth because you know
Earth is kind of bare and evidently at
this point and they're there and they're
it's it's kind of an allegory for the
Garden of Eden Kirk Douglas name is Adam
Farrah Fawcett's kind of playing an Eve
type character who she's never been to
earth and she's kind of naive and
probably 30-something years younger than
him and and they're they're in a
relationship and then a serpent shows up
and the form Harvey Keitel and Harvey
Keitel's this bad dude you know and he
assembles this robot you find out that
he's basically you know a cyber stalker
that he had been stalking Farrah
Fawcett's somehow or another he knew she
was out there and he killed the do
that was supposed to be on the mission
and took his place yeah brought that
robot with it he gets there under false
pretenses so he can get close to her
it's a pretty cool flick mayhem ensues
well the movie had kind of a troubled
production history yeah it was made as a
result of the success of alien and
earlier Star Wars probably hmm
originally it was supposed to be
directed by John Barry who was the
production designer on Superman and
might have done some work on Star Wars -
yeah he was Empire Strikes Back
yeah yeah he worked on Empire Strikes
Back now for whatever reason I can't
revert exactly what the reason was I
don't know if there was creative
differences but John Berry was taken off
the project now he died not long
afterward but the project was then given
to Stanley Donen who had been the
producer now Stanley Donen had never
directed a sci-fi or horror movie before
he was actually known for doing musicals
he had done singing in the rain Seven
Brides for Seven Brothers funny face
that kind of thing so it's kind of a
strange juxtaposition and I should say
that Saturn three is generally pretty
poorly reviewed yeah but I actually now
I'm not gonna say I mean obviously it's
not as good as alien it's not as good as
some of the other sci-fi that came out
for the period but actually I don't I
can understand why some people didn't
like it but I actually thought it was
pretty good I thought was a very good
sci-fi movie for the time the sets are
really nice I really like yeah the the
sets of this of the base where they live
the sets are kind of in between say
Death Star and the Death Star and alien
yeah and it's kind of cool the way it's
set up there's a lot of hallways and
little rooms and in between the hallways
and rooms you see the interior parts of
the cave and it looks kind of cool the
robot looks good it's a robot of its
time but it was futuristic in the day
yeah Harvey Keitel's pressure suits this
you know which is he comes in his
pressure suit he's got a couple of
little leather pressure suit out for the
fits
where's actually looks very high-quality
and and the blu-ray some people have
said that Kirk Douglas and Farrah
Fawcett's costumes kind of look 70ish
and they do in the DVD and VHS transfers
and on YouTube they did but when you see
the blu-ray which I have the blu-ray you
can see the texture of the materials
there are very high quality sets very
high quality costumes to me it looks 80s
you know and with Harvey Keitel's like
he had like this green looks like green
leather pants yeah yeah but when you see
it in blu-ray it's actually kind they're
kind of like PVC green metal flake yeah
is what it looked like or pearlescent
looking pressure suit tight pants it
looked really cool I thought there were
there were problems in the script I
think they ran out of money because well
yeah ended too quickly that's the
problem
there was good build-up it had a good
beginning a middle but the end seemed
like 15 minutes of action were missing
yeah they seemed a little rushed yeah
seemed like they just okay we gotta end
this movie there was a thing where now
the amount of money that this movie was
supposed to get I think at some point
during the production the production
company was like no we're gonna make
this other movie that we think it was
actually raised the Titanic that they
actually had more faith in as a project
so they took some money away from Saturn
3 and gave it to the other movie race
the Titanic which was also a flop Saturn
3 didn't actually do that bad at the
box-office
considering it wasn't a hugely expensive
movie to make I think it kind of
occupies a similar kind of space as the
black hole maybe where it's kind if it's
a similar kind of the story isn't really
similar really but in quality of
production it kind of it's kind of like
yeah it's it's kind of similar in
quality and similar in the sense that it
seems to have inspired either well I
don't know if anybody like loves this
movie like favorite movie ever it's a go
it's a cult movie yeah but I'm a lot of
a cult following but then a lot of moot
people really seemed to think it was
pretty bad but I don't think it was any
cheesier actually I think it was less
cheesy than the black hole yeah what is
cheesy that's cheesy them and uh like I
said not a great sci-fi movie but really
I think the premise of it is
Primus I like the premise of the main
robot Hector being an extension of a
psychopath yeah I think is an intriguing
idea yeah we don't want to spoil too
much this is something that you have to
see for yourself
this movie deserves to be watched it
deserves to be remembered and when you
see it in blu-ray because you can watch
this for free on YouTube just search for
it you'll find somebody who posted it
with a Cyrillic name it's in Russia he
posted it it's watchable that version
but the blu-ray version the sets and all
the props it looks so much better even
they did spend money on this movie it's
just like I said but like I said before
it's as if about ten minutes of the end
or missing that's all it always felt
that way to me
yeah it ended a little too quickly there
wasn't enough action at the very end
yeah but other than that decent movie
decent movie especially for its time and
I think in some ways ahead of its time
like Harvey Keitel's plays the villain
and I really like this character he's
come from kind of a broken-down version
of the world they take lots of drugs
they're psychos in a way they they're
into instant gratification they don't
have any social skills a lot of
technological skills though so they're
kind of like some of these kids you see
with their faces buried into it and into
a cell phone and just social media but
they can't do with you face to face
harley harvey keitel is like an extreme
version of that almost kind of like
autistic in a certain way but he's also
hostile no so no social skills at all he
just basically goes up to fare and goes
I like your body can I use it you know
and then when she says no she was like
that's a crime you know cuz everything
for them is like porn and instant
gratification yeah and he I mean he
feels entitled to her when he gets there
and he makes the point and in some way I
think that some people are creeped out
by the fact that there is a sexual
relationship between Kirk Douglas and
Farrah Fawcett but in a way that kind of
plays into the movie because Marty
Keitel who is much younger presumably
handsomer I would guess so he comes to
their almost like like you said
serpent in the Garden of Eden like to
tempt her right away from her older
quote/unquote useless guy who's maybe
come into his retirement or whatever
yeah but I so I kind of like that they
had that dynamic going yeah
I don't want to ruin too much of it but
yeah I did like that there's a little
bit of Frankenstein in this - yeah
there's a transhuman element going on
here - because not only is carving
harvey keitel kind of futuristic and
weird and dysfunctional he's also a
cyborg yeah it's sort of yeah that he
has a port in the back of his head and
he can wirelessly communicate or in
program this we are calling it a robot
Hector but Hector is also a cyborg
inside of its body is like a three foot
long vat of artificially grown brain
material that's its central so it has an
organic organic component and it's
learning from him because normally it
would take decades to properly evidently
according to adam takes decades to
properly program an AI robot but he says
not on a not not with this one you know
and so it's gonna be kind of like a
brain to brain communication and
Keitel's character his name is Benson
captain Benson captain Benson says he
only learns what I tell him to learn you
know or what I let him learn from me but
he mentions later on that Hector finds
out some of his secrets having to do
with murders that were committed and he
says block that that's an that was an
unintentional leakage yeah so this is
brain leakage yes Hector is learning
things by accident - the things that
Benson doesn't want to teach him and you
find out that part of the reason why a
lot of stuff goes wrong is that Benson
failed the course on how to have a
management program yeah he wasn't
supposed he was gonna show you yeah I've
heard in some of the comments sexist oh
why didn't he know this he built that
road he didn't build it he assembled it
he failed he failed the test right
that's why Ellison go another guy was
supposed right he was unworthy to even
have to
that was the guy that was supposed to go
with me Adam mentions that yeah I may be
old and I'm not cool enough to kill
people you know because he was saying
that cool guys back on earth actually
killed people yeah he hadn't been to
earth for a very long time so we're
never shown what earth is like is like
right we don't know all the implications
evidently not that good and uh Farrah
Fawcett's character has never been to
earth she wasn't born there but the
movie deserves to be watched and I
recommend the blu-ray the blu-ray
version this movie looks three times
better than it really does look nice the
sets are very nice yeah it looks a lot
better so it makes a lot better
impression on you than the free you -
yeah well it looks cheap it looks very
cheap the proof if you watch like a like
a cheap transfer of it yeah it looks
really cheap it looks bad on par with a
bad transfer of Logan's Run yeah or
maybe like an episode of Battlestar
Galactica yeah you know but yeah it
looks like a TV yeah there's some
made-for-tv but that's not the way the
blu-ray looks yeah array in certain
scenes looks modern it looks like
something from 2000 something I really I
like the use of blue I like like all the
lights and stuff like that it's really
cool-looking I mean obviously a lot of
it is more atmospheric than functional
but they do that in a lot of sci-fi
movies yeah it looks cool and you know
it doesn't matter yeah the worst part of
the movie where was these the external
shots of outer space with the ships and
yeah cuz the lot was miniatures and
stuff miniatures and who it was on par
with say like a Japanese Toho flick from
the 70s uh you know it didn't have the
thought of the flames of going in the
wrong direction of the fire going up it
wasn't that bad but the outer space
shots were inferior even for 1980 oh
yeah I didn't look it's gonna start oh
no and one of the shots I was almost
like a star crash one of them was that
bad yes that's a similar level now when
he goes through the rings of Saturn in
this they did it with some a mirrors of
little foam rocks floating on water and
the camera going in between him it was
kind of a psychedelic effect yeah that
it didn't look realistic that's one
thing I did like about the movie is that
when it kinda overreached instead of
going for realism they just went for
psychedelic
yeah just a trip yeah which you
is a good option no it didn't look real
but it still looked kind of cool like it
is stylized yeah that's that's a date
Russian you know that's fair enough they
can do that and the same kind of thing
with the design of Hector the robot
which I actually really liked I liked
that he was very I mean that was
industrial kind of looking it was
obviously a guy in a suit yeah you know
so they just built the suit around him
so it was just this big hulking it
almost had like musculature kind of yeah
the bike that if wires and tubes and
stuff yeah it was kind of cool and he
didn't really have a head which I
thought made him creepier yeah we he
gets a head later on yeah okay I want to
mention too that that's not Harvey
Keitel's voice and I didn't know that
yeah
now I didn't realize while I was
watching it because the way that Harvey
Keitel's character of Benson is in this
movie yeah he seems very I mean he's
obviously a psychopath he's not socially
adept no he's not you know a
conversation he comes across as very
cold very sterols talking like he's a
robot he's talking as though he's a
robot which to me like kind of he sounds
like a walking youtube comment section
yeah a little bit yeah he's no social
skills right yeah so to me I didn't know
until later on but to me that just kind
of played into his character and it does
actually kind of sound a little bit like
Harvey Keitel I thought it was Harvey's
good um I haven't heard him in a movie
in a while so I couldn't really remember
so I did so it didn't weird me out or
anything but then later on I found out
that he was completely dubbed completely
dubbed by a British actor called Roy
dotrice who I think he's has been in
Game of Thrones as if he's an old man
but you know he's been into is a great
deaf job though yeah he didn't do a
British accent he did like a
transatlantic a transatlantic sort of
accent because the problem evidently was
that after Saturn 3 was shot the
director decided that he didn't like
Harvey Keitel's Brooklyn accent which I
didn't think it fit in with a dead a
[ __ ] so evidently they asked Harvey
Keitel to come back and overdub his
lines with a more
accent but he didn't want to do it yeah
so they got someone else in to dub him
over it's funny because it's he's doing
a good harvey keitel yeah occurred to me
that it hurt me that was it sounds like
him sounds like him doing a
transatlantic yeah accent and it did fit
in with the character so it didn't
immediately it didn't like it wasn't
awkward although I thought to me I think
a Brooklyn accent also would have fit
with that character and the way that
they were trying to describe the way the
earth was maybe you know they were
saying the earth was pretty bad well
maybe kind of like a Brooklyn gangster
mobster kind of a accent might have
worked a high tech from Brooklyn might
work I can see why he made that
directorial decision think they wanted
him to be a little more alien that's
what I mean and that's how he came
across he came across as almost inhuman
because when he first came to the planet
I had seen this movie many years ago but
I'd kind of forgotten what happened in
it so when we watched it again for the
review when he first got to the planet
and started talking
I'm like is he a robot like is it you
know like you know the guy and on the
ship an alien that's a cyborg but I was
like is he supposed to be a cyborg
because he's talking like that but in a
way it made him creepier made it made
him seem a little bit more otherworldly
so I don't think that was necessarily a
bad decision even though it was kind of
a what the [ __ ] kind of did it he wasn't
a robot any but he was a cyborg yeah in
the way that he was a man with
cybernetic implants Plantae and he was a
technophile in his jaggus his job was to
program robots but he failed the test he
wasn't as good as he that's why he
didn't get that's why that's why he
didn't get sent but he made sure he was
gonna go yeah and it was to get it Farah
yeah what I don't I don't think that
they specifically mentioned that in the
movie that that's why he went on that
particular thing but I guess that's
implied it's implied because he expects
her to be there because he knows the
shows about her when he gets there yeah
I also want to mention too since we're
talking about Farrah Fawcett a lot of
the international marketing for this
movie I just totally the poster and
stuff like that had a very famous image
of Farrah Fawcett in this crazy
Sipho die 5 fetish she Barbarella
kind of looking outfit and this big
teased hair and every yeah I thought it
was from a deleted scene that's on the
blu-ray yeah now if you watch the movie
just the regular cut of the movie that
scene is not in there but on the blu-ray
the deleted scene is there now
I believe she asked to be asked for it
to be taken out and they took it and
then the director thought yeah maybe we
should take that out and in a way I'm
glad they took it out made the movie a
little more serious a little stronger
yeah because I think that scene was
unnecessary and I think had you left
that scene in then I mean it was bad
enough that Farrah Fawcett I mean she'd
been on Charlie's Angels she was a pinup
and everything like that so she was
already gonna get accusations of that's
why she's in this movie because we want
teenage boys to see it and you know you
get to see her boobies and stuff like
that yeah it's there's a topless flash
it's not yeah she's not like running
around naked oh she Norma Shearer eight
she it most of the movie she just has
regular clothes on yeah yeah there is a
flash of boob you do get to see her
boobs not a big deal though but it's not
a big mostly Kirk Douglas run around
naked yeah they couldn't get his clothes
on pretty clothes on no no I'm very
unconscious but I'm gonna keep it like
Harvey Keitel's he wanted to eat dinner
with him with his shirt off yeah that's
some behind-the-scenes stuff yeah that's
what we heard about B Kirk Douglas they
couldn't get teller I run around like a
naked boy yeah get all the time but yeah
so Nikki and he was in good shape for 64
yes yeah he was 64 when it was filmed
but yeah so I think I'm glad that they
took that out because I think you take
ferry's character more seriously yeah
yeah you see her boobs yeah it's like
her and Kirk heaven it was just a good
time though but yeah it's not I I didn't
find it egregious and she didn't come
off like a bimbo which I like just
normal girl like she didn't come across
like a genius or anything like that like
they weren't trying to make her a
scientist or anything no but she just
comes across like a normal person and
like I said I kind of like that even
though it's you know Garden of Eden
metaphor and the serpent everything like
that that doesn't you know even though
the serpent is supposed to be the
tempter and everything
the storyline doesn't necessarily go the
way you think that that would be implied
with with that
yeah I have to say you know Farrah
Fawcett couldn't act her way out of a
paper bag
okay but this is her best work she was
and she's pretty good when she did some
dramas later on in the 80s like the
burning bed which is about spousal abuse
and stuff like that I think she was
pretty good in that she got better than
she was so yeah so I think she got
better over the abyss was before the
Hollywood cocaine monster got a hold
over - yeah so she she was totally
passable in this age she nothing she did
like stood out as being cringe worthy
she just seemed like a she wasn't being
crazy yeah she wasn't being crazy I
didn't get the sense that she was just
in it as tits and ass I mean she was in
it as a real person as what she but this
character is no Ripley from a well no no
she's obvious she's still a little bit
of a damsel in distress but not not to
an unrealistic - great right I mean she
is a little bit sheltered but she's
lived out on this moon pretty much her
whole life
yeah I guess that's is what they imply
er she has never been to earth and yeah
they don't I don't think they ever say
where she was born or where she's from
somewhere else but not earth yeah but so
she's just lived out here in this
idyllic kind of exert Doug listen we're
also kind of led to believe that no
there like I said before there are no
nation-states their property of this
company they have tattoos on their faces
yeah they may be slaves probably no yeah
maybe transfer them around wherever they
need them well they need a because the
curtain Adam Kirk Douglas he's talking
about retirement day and retire and what
are they talking about Dan do they kill
him Ella hell that day yeah that's never
really yeah yeah but that could be the
implication though maybe it could be
like everybody's to Logan's Run you know
in for all we know they're clones yeah
they could be that too we have to be a
lot going on in there that we run know
about right because you know they don't
they don't set up the whole society they
don't set up what exactly is going on
but they just give you like a little bit
of information and you can kind of fill
in the gaps yourself you know for this
story so like I said even though I mean
I have read some positive reviews of
this but most of the reviews are fairly
negative but I but most emotive by
people who are not sci-fi fans all their
young people who are kind of particular
we'll be out of the context of the day -
I didn't really I mean I didn't think it
was all that bad and like I said I think
it came out pretty decent for the amount
of difficulties that reduction went
through yeah you know so and the fact
that it was directed by somebody that
had never done a sci-fi movie before I
mean it's a pretty respectable yeah yeah
it's kind of a ripoff of alien no yes
yeah it's not perfect but it was better
than a lot of the sci-fi trash that just
doesn't exist anymore from that time
yeah cuz a lot of it shits just don't
wait oh yeah I mean [ __ ] look at already
good look at all the crappy sci-fi that
came out it does like you mentioned star
crash boom yeah which was well those
have been oh that one it's like funny
well those were preserved because they
were so bad yeah that they had to just
be kept for posterity I mean next to
star crash yeah
Saturn 3 looks like [ __ ] Citizen Kane
oh yeah yeah yeah like I said though
earlier this movie really could have
been something if there was about 15
more minutes of exciting material at the
end yeah bolstered the endings that's
what stretched it out a little bit may
to give it more suspense and I think a
lot of a lot of the the modern
complaints about this movie would vanish
if there was something at the end like
an end kind of like terminator you know
I mean the way this I can't don't want
to spoil it it's just that there there
wasn't enough payoff there's a lot of
buildup not enough yeah I agree with
that
the ending was a little abrupt right so
I think the movie is good it's there
context like sci-fi from that time I
definitely think it's work worth
watching
it's not a classic obviously but I look
at it as a Alien franchise and Blade
Runner franchise spin-off movie is that
it's it's hanging in the same universe
but out on a-- but out like way out look
at this movie yeah I could see that yeah
yeah but you know it's like I said if
you're in a cipher from that era it's
pretty it's it's worth watching yeah I
didn't think it was that bad and that
was good it's pretty good alright okay
so that will do it for our latest movie
review remember if you liked the show to
like share subscribe on all your social
media and if
like to support the show remember to
check out our patreon page at
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock or go to
our blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress comm and there's a link in the
sidebar to a paypal account if you'd
like to give a one-time donation also
remember to check out our regular
episodes that come out every Tuesday and
our movie reviews that come out every
Friday and until next time bye